10 Minute NFL Games... and 6 other Sports
Facts
1.
“Soccer” was once a popular name for Football
in Britain in the sport’s earliest days.
When the rules for the sport were first being
defined, it was named “Association Football”
to distinguish it from the other forms of
football commonly played.
Within a year of its inception, this got slurred
down to “Assoccer,” after the common practice
of adding “-er” to nicknames at the time
in Britain.
Very shortly after this, “Assoccer” became
“Soccer,” which remained a semi-popular
nickname for the sport in Britain until about
a half century ago, along with just “Football.”
The game initially spread throughout the world
primarily known as “Football.”
However, in countries where other forms of
football (games played on foot rather than
on horseback) already were dominate, the nickname
“Soccer” was, and in some cases still
is, the preferred name for this reason.
(QF 761)
2.
According to a recent Wall Street Journal
study, the average NFL game features only
10 minutes and 43 seconds of action.
The rest of the time is spent with commercials,
replays and commentary.
This makes it possibly the most profitable
10-11 minutes of entertainment in the history
of sports, particularly if you include the
countless hours spent on sports talk radio
and TV shows that continue to talk about the
games and teams even in the off-season, all
the while generating advertising revenue.
(QF 780)
3.
Magic Johnson signed a $25 million, 25 year
contract with the Lakers in 1981, the highest
paying contract in sports history at the time.
This comprised the bulk of his earnings from
his playing career (though of course he didn’t
complete the contract).
Today, Magic Johnson Enterprises is estimated
to be worth nearly $1 billion, including,
among many other things, owning several fast
food restaurants and 24-Hour Fitness locations…
which is sort of the perfect scheme if you
think about it.
(QF 607)
4.
Despite that many in the media claimed the
Seattle Seahawks’ Super Bowl victory was
the first major professional sporting championship
won by a Seattle based professional team,
this isn’t true at all.
For starters, in 1917 the Seattle Metropolitans
became the first American team to win the
Stanley Cup.
Further, the 1979 Seattle Super Sonics won
the NBA championship.
In more recent memory, the Seattle Storm won
the WNBA championship in 2004 and 2010 . Incidentally,
the Seattle Metropolitans also played in the
Stanley Cup finals in 1919.
With the series tied 2-2-1, the finals were
canceled due to the Spanish flu pandemic that
killed about 3%-5% of the human population,
as well as infecting about 30%.
(QF 743)
5.
During King Edward’s reign (1307-1327),
he had laws passed against the playing of
various football sports.
Anyone caught playing any form of football
would be imprisoned, “For as much as there
is a great noise in the city caused by hustling
over large balls, from which many evils may
arise…”
He wasn’t the only British monarch that
hated football sports.
Queen Elizabeth I “had football players
jailed for a week, with follow-up church penance.”
King Henry IV and Henry VIII also passed laws
against football sports.
(QF 771)